it's time for the long gene kana scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene with nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our co
editors for this edition of the
launching Khurana scope Larry Mercer
from the CBS television News staff and
Louis banks associate editor of Time
magazine our distinguished guest for
this evening is the honorable john c
Stennis senator from Mississippi I think
it's only fair to say that during the
past year the United States Senate
itself has been under considerable
pressure
it's labored in an atmosphere which has
brought connotations of irresponsibility
exhibitionism and even lowered standards
now it speaks for the esteem in which
our guest tonight is held by his fellow
senators that he was chosen by the
Senate to appear and who we represent
them on the watkins committee senator
Stennis does this Watkins committee
report touch on the subject of how much
power a congressional committee should
have yes it does that's one of the main
points involved in the report but before
I say anything about the report let me
emphasize that I make no comment here
about the allegations so far they
pertain to Senator McCarthy his
innocence or his guilt I'm just
discussing the legal principles involved
and you've mentioned one of the main
ones you know we have the age-old
conflict between the executive branch of
the government the presidency which has
certain power to withhold information
and keep secret high matters on our
security front and then the legislative
branch which is the Congress having the
right to make investigations primarily
for two purposes one to determine what
bases to pass the laws on what are the
facts with reference to needed
legislation and then to see also if the
laws we already have will be
properly carried out or executed well
the money is being properly spent so
that that line of division between the
executive and the legislative has never
been clearly defined the conflict has
gone on from George Washington's time
down until today the senator does the
Watkins committee report actually
crystallized these areas this
ill-defined area between the legislative
and the executives power no it makes no
crystal clear mark line between the two
it points out the problem it recognizes
there is a field of investigation
there's a field where the executive has
the right to hold back sight and the
information is secured to the nation
being involved but it does point out
this that with these with the increased
budget with enormous expenditures that
we have the budget having increased from
three billion dollars annually to sixty
billion dollars annually with our
far-flung military installations all
over the world and particularly in view
of our worldwide fight against communism
international conspiracies that there's
more need for investigations at the same
time there's more need for security
information being kept secret on the
certain circumstances well senator what
student yes what little changes does the
Senate need in order to bring its tomato
now mechanism up we we did not rec we
did not recommend in a legislation on
this very important but and vexing
subject but we did recommend this that
the heads of the Senate or committees
and also the ranking member of the party
out of power meet with the executive
heads of the departments of government
and see if there could not be a plan
worked out not necessarily by a rule of
law but by the spirit of cooperation
where the integrity of the president's
power would be preserved the integrity
of the legislative power and
responsibilities would be preserved and
all of it wiped out or the protection
and benefit of the people as a whole and
a great deal
it's already being done along that line
I can assure you and the people but more
needs to be done and we may have to have
new legislation because the statutes
that control this proposition as to how
far the executive can go on how much the
how far the legislature can go and how
much the executive can withhold not
clearly defined senator Stennis it's as
you realize it's all very well to come
to an agreement on just what a committee
should do but the chairman of a Senate
committee has vast powers is there any
way to enforce any rule change well
we've had we've had yes you can enforce
rules on that we have had rather big and
loose rules on the matter I say this
investigatory power has not been this
extended then it's important as it has
become the last few years now the rules
are are not definite on that it's left
has been left in part to the standards
that the committee itself might set
which the Chairman might set now we feel
that the Senate must re-examine this
must reappraise it and we definitely
recommended here a start on some
additional rules one is that no witness
should be compelled to testify unless at
least two members of the Senate present
unless he waives that right unless the
whole committee votes to authorize the
chairman to proceed another thing that
the witness could be interrogated only
by a member of the Senate or a staff
member chosen by the committee
not just the chairman but by the
committee I'll follow that purpose and
another thing we recommended that no
committee chairman be permitted to
disclose what went on in the executive
session executive hearing unless the
committee votes that it be disclosed we
put another provision on our
recommendation that no payments could be
made for the expenses of this committee
until it had complied with his rule that
he has a chairman certified senator
centers may ask did you touch upon the
so-called rights of government employees
to pass on classified material to
members of Congress
well that's that's in the report and
what we said on that speaks for itself
now that goes right back to the first
point I mention here about the line
being somewhat vague and uncertain in
places the executive branch the
government undoubtedly has a power to
withhold certain information and to put
executive orders that will keep those
files protect those files senator I
suspect it
one key question of it should be
answered is whether you think the Senate
is going to back up the Watkins
committee censured well I'd like I don't
want to pass on that in any way that's
each individual senator must make up his
own mind it presents a question that he
has to fly his own standards of thinking
and his own concept of Senator conduct
and the proper exercise of Senate or of
power oh I have already reached my
conclusions but that's the matter that
each senator must decide for himself
this is it does involve the Senate I
think the senatorial question is
involved but each individual senator has
to make up law senator centers I know
you have compelling reasons for not
wanting to predict what the Senate will
do on the Watkins committee report on
Senator McCarthy I wonder if I could put
the question this way could you tell us
what material effect it would have on a
senator if the Senate passed a vote of
censure against him well that's entirely
conjectural I I wouldn't want to go into
that it depends upon so many factors the
case the case has not been concluded and
having reached that part of it and I
would respectfully withhold or comment
asunder in a political year wouldn't it
have been easier for your committee to
duck a decision on this and just you
weren't absolutely ordered to bring in a
decision well we were in order to make
recommendations specific but you say a
political year now we were appointed in
a non-political atmosphere the
resolution said three Democrats and
three Republicans and that's the last
time though
woods we use the hood we had no
suggestions whatsoever from any outside
source all among ourselves about the
political implications or the line of
political parties with reference to this
decision
we weren't Olly free of that so after
the evidence was heard and considered
why they had instructed us to hear the
testimony and to report and we the
report speaks for itself as to what we
decided we thought we were following a
line of duty ruffles to that senator
sent us of course you're a member of the
Armed Services Committee beside this
special yes Watkins committee I'd like
to ask you something about a new factor
that's arisen now how do you people on
the or you yourself feel on the Senate
Armed Services Committee about the
reality of West Germany well I feel and
I think most members of feel that it's
necessary to rearm Germany in order to
protect the situation in Europe I was in
Europe a year ago I thought then that
EDC would not be ratified by France and
that came to a head this last September
one France turn the EDC down I felt like
it we should have another proposal and
alternative and that has materialized
and apparently it is going to prevail
which will lead to a rearming of Germany
which is a necessary step I think to
preserve protect Europe incidentally I
think that we are gaining in the Cold
War another one that you're a man of
much wisdom and no moderation in the
Senate how do you feel actually we're
doing in this cold war now are we
winning or well are we losing I feel
that we are gaining in Europe yes I
think definitely so we make a fairly
steady progress and another step is
about to be taking this rearm in Germany
to be frank I think we are losing in
Asia I don't try to put that blame on
anyone I think it's largely the course
of events I don't say we've lost
everything but I think the trend there
has been against us
it's a long long ways off as much
territory involved many many countries
many many many people
well senator do you think we could
actually do anything to stem the tide of
communism over there well I feel that
communism of a kind is on the ascendancy
in Asia it's so moving along slowly I
hope it's not all together the Russian
communism I hope it's a different type I
believe it is too but that trend is on
the move and I think it it we must help
[ __ ] it but it's got to be wiped out
by the age attic people I see well thank
you very much senator Stennis it's very
kind of you to come up from Washington
talk to us tonight the opinions
expressed on the lawn Jane crow no scope
were those of the speakers the editorial
board for this edition of the Long Jean
Cronus cope was Larry Mercer and Lewis
banks our distinguished guests was the
honorable john c Stennis senator from
Mississippi